[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen fußball
die großen themen dieser sendung im
überblick
[Musik]
gedenkfeiern für die opfer des 11
september in den usa erinnern sie an die
menschen die vor 20 jahren bei den
terroranschlägen ums leben gekommen sind
demonstrative einigkeit im
wahlkampf-endspurt unions kandidat armin
laschet bekommt auf dem csu-parteitag
rückendeckung aus bayern
stark gespielt und doch verloren
alexanders wäre scheitert im halbfinale
der us open an novak djokovic
nine eleven das datum das für die
schlimmsten terroranschläge in der
geschichte der usa steht mit großen
gedenkzeremonien wird heute genau 20
jahre nach den al kaida attacken an die
opfer erinnert das ist für mich die
zentrale lektion von nine eleven wenn
wir am verletzlichsten sind ist einheit
unsere größte stärke sagte us-präsident
beiden zum jahrestag
rückblick am 11 september 2001 um 80 46
ortszeit schlägt das erste flugzeug ins
world trade center ein kurz nach neun
das zweite eine halbe stunde später rast
eine dritte maschine ins pentagon bei
washington der vierte stürzte im
bundesstaat pennsylvania auf ein feld
2977 menschen kommen ums leben tausende
werden verletzt die seelischen wunden
schmerzen überlebende und angehörige bis
heute benjamin daniel
im sonst so lauten amerika ist es heute
vielerorts ganz oft ganz leise wie hier
am ground zero in new york city
joe biden barack obama bill clinton
seite an seite während der ersten
schweigeminute 8 uhr 46 es ist der
zeitpunkt zu dem am 11 september 2001
das erste flugzeug in den nordturm
einschlägt may close tochter sarah war
flugbegleiterin auf der maschine
es fühlte sich an als würde ein böses
gespenst auf die erde herab steigen aber
es war auch ein tag an dem viele
menschen unglaubliches geleistet haben
diese bilder werden heute 20 jahre alt
sie dokumentieren eine zäsur nein wie
leveln angriff auf amerika in einer ganz
neuen dimension
große gedenkfeiern auch am pentagon und
in shanksville pennsylvania hier stürzte
ein flugzeug ab dass die terroristen
wollen ins weiße haus oder in den
kongress linken wollten crew und
passagiere sorgten dafür dass die
maschine ihr ziel nicht erreichte der
damalige präsident george hw bush
würdigte die helden von flug 93 und
machte klar er ist davon überzeugt dass
amerika wieder zusammenwachsen können
heutzutage wird politik oft missbraucht
um angst zu verbreiten und die menschen
zu verärgern deshalb machen wir uns
gemeinsam sorgen um die zukunft unserer
nation aber gleichzeitig sehe ich eine
junge generation die sich für die
gesellschaft selbstlos engagiert das ist
das land das ich kenne
die straße ist lang und wirkt endlos
singt bruce springsteen der elfte
september 2001 hat für die usa vieles
verändert den internationalen terror hat
amerika aber nicht besiegt die
bedrohungen im eigenen land sind sogar
noch größer geworden
[Musik]
sprechen wir dazu mit unseren
korrespondenten johannes hano und katrin
eigendorf johannes hano ist für uns bei
den gedenkfeierlichkeiten in new york
johannes welche spuren haben die
terroranschläge 20 jahre danach in der
stadt im ganzen land hinterlassen
ich glaube darauf gibt es zwei antworten
einmal eine of new york gezogen und
einmal auf das land new york haben diese
anschläge letztlich stärker gemacht new
york ist stärker aus diesen anschlägen
der vorgegangen als es vorher war man
hat sich trotzig selbstbewusst in großer
solidarität dieser katastrophe hingegen
gestellt hat die stadt neu erfunden neu
aufgebaut das hat einen enormen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung genommen und
man denkt hier sehr oft an einen delap
und jetzt auch während co wird weil man
sagt wir haben das damals durch
gestanden wir haben das damals geschafft
werden das auch jetzt schaffen wenn man
das allerdings auf das ganze land
betrachtet diese frage da muss man sagen
ist amerika mittlerweile viel
zerrissener als es vorher war von
solidarität die man hier in new york
unter den new yorkern spürt spürt man in
dem land relativ wenig ich bin gerade
unterwegs gewesen in dem land hat mir
das alles angeschaut also wenig
solidarität viel zwietracht und zwist
das ist sind zwei unterschiedliche
antworten und amerika werden wir von den
usa nach afghanistan dort ist chance
katrin eigendorf kathrin als reaktion
auf nine eleven vertrieben die usa die
taliban von der macht weil sie al kaida
den drahtziehern der anschläge
unterschlupf gewährt hatten heute 20
jahre später herrschen die taliban
wieder in afghanistan
wie groß ist da durch die jetzt als die
gefahr dass von dort wieder
terroranschläge verübt werden
das wird man noch sehen müssen aber es
ist einfach eine tatsache dass die
taliban ja in ihren eigenen reihen
international gesuchte terroristen haben
es ist auch klar dass die verbindung zu
al qaida nie wirklich abgebrochen wurde
und es ist im moment auch die frage wer
wird sich hier durchsetzen die die er
das programmieren was im moment auf der
weltbühne zu sehen ist nämlich zu
versuchen gute beziehungen zum westen
auch zu pflegen weil sie auf hilfsgelder
angewiesen sind oder die hardliner die
aufgrund konfrontieren wollen und hier
eine wirklich er terroristische linie
fahren ganz sicher ist afghanistan unter
dem regime der taliban eine bedrohung
für die welt mit der man im kunden
künftig rechnen muss vielen dank für
diese ein schätzung katrin eigendorf und
johannes hano
immer noch versuchen in afghanistan
viele menschen vor der taliban
herrschaft zu fliehen aber die lage wird
immer aussichtsloser
die nachbarländer haben ihre grenzen
weitgehend dicht gemacht sowie pakistan
auch mit einem visum kommen afghanen und
afghaninnen nur noch schwer ins land
unsere reporterin susanne santina
berichtet aus tor kam einem der
wichtigsten übergänge zwischen
afghanistan und pakistan
sie verstecken sich in den lastwagen
afghanische kinder machten heute den
pakistanischen grenze soldaten die
meiste arbeit auch wenn sie vielleicht
nur kurz nach pakistan wollten um tabak
oder batterien zu verkaufen sie hatten
keine chance
hunderte andere afghanen waren besser
dran sie alle haben
ausnahmegenehmigungen vom pakistanischen
innenministeriums oder papiere die sie
zur weiterreise in ein anderes land
berechtigen dann werden sie von taliban
und pakistanischen soldaten
durchgelassen
wir hatten keine wahl wir können nicht
unter diesen mörderischen taliban
in afghanistan gibt es nichts mehr
keinen frieden keine bildung die
wirtschaft am boden wir sind froh hier
zu sein
es kommen immer mehr und rund vier
millionen afghanische flüchtlinge leben
in pakistan schon seit jahrzehnten die
regierung fühlt sich von reicheren
staaten im stich gelassen worden
pakistan will stabilität in afghanistan
das land fürchtet nichts mehr als dass
wieder millionen flüchtlinge kommen
deswegen wird man mit den taliban
zusammen arbeiten
heute verlief der
pakistanisch-afghanischen grenze
weitgehend friedlich anders als ende
august
salz ihren talk am mehrere afghanen
versuchten illegal die grenze zu
übertreten
die pakistanische armee hat daraufhin
das feuer eröffnet und mindestens drei
afghanische frauen wurden getötet die
pakistanische armee bedauert solche
vorfälle und warnt afghanen bekommen für
pakistan keine visa mehr
mit schwierigen gesprächsthemen gepäck
es bundeskanzlerin merkel zu einem ihrer
letzten offiziellen auslandsbesuch nach
polen gereist bei ihrem treffen mit
ministerpräsident noda wiki sagte merkel
streitthemen wie die polnische justiz
reform sollten durch politische
gespräche gelöst werden und nicht durch
gerichte beide betonten das russische
gas exporte auch künftig durch polen
nach westeuropa fließen sollten
nach deutschland bei neuen protesten
gegen die internationale
automobilausstellung in münchen ist es
heute weitgehend friedlich geblieben
die demonstrierenden fordern eine
mobilitäts wände und werfen den
autokonzernen vor zu wenig für den
klimaschutz zu tun laut polizei nahm
mehr als 10.000 menschen teil die
veranstalter sprechen von rund 25.000
seit tagen kommt es immer wieder zu
protestaktionen gegen die automesse ein
bisschen weiter nördlich in bayern in
nürnberg war heute unions
kanzlerkandidat lasche zu gast beim
csu-parteitag nachdem es aus bayern
immer wieder spitzen gegen ihn gegeben
hatte setzte die csu jetzt auf
demonstrative geschlossenheit der
schwesterparteien für seine rede bekam
laschet minutenlang applaus er griff
darin vor allem die spd scharf an
alexander pohl
[Applaus]
will die kanzler als armin laschet
es wirkt fast so als könne armin laschet
nicht glauben was er sieht gut für armin
armin rufe aus einer partei die lange
mit ihrem gehadert hatte heute ist die
csu auf harmonie programmiert der
kanzlerkandidat hatte für die
christsozialen aber auch lang ersehnte
wahlkampf botschaften mitgebracht und
ein zitat von franz josef strauß
franz josef strauß hat ja mal gesagt
irren ist menschlich immer irren ist
sozialdemokratisch
spd und grüne in der bundesregierung
führen zu weniger sicherheit in
deutschland und das dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren
mit blick auf die nahende bundestagswahl
sahen die delegierten heute einen
anderen einen kämpferischen armin
laschet ja wir waren alle business cap
gefühl dass werden wenn er jetzt kommt
das ist wie wenn neue lehrer kommt ich
glaube alles was er gesagt hat kann ich
zu hundert prozent unterschreiben von
daher glaube ich war das heute noch mal
das signal dass jetzt alle gebraucht
haben die letzten 14 tage nochmal gas zu
geben denn cdu und csu brauchen dringend
eine trendwende
mit dem heutigen empfang für armin
laschet ist dass markus söder und der
csu gelungen beide schwesterparteien
wieder zusammenzuführen das bedeutet
nicht dass jeder delegierte jetzt
restlos überzeugt ist von armin laschet
aber es gibt nun mal nur den einen
kanzlerkandidaten der union und mit dem
will die csu trotz der schlechten
ausgangslage am 26 september die
bundestagswahl gewinnen
gegen zu hohe mieten und für mehr
wohnraum sind in berlin mehrere tausend
menschen auf die straße gegangen dazu
aufgerufen hatte das bündnis gegen
falsche rechnung und mietenwahnsinn
unter dem motto wohnen für alle
forderten die demonstrierenden einen
bundesweiten mieten deckel sowie die
enteignung großer immobilienkonzerne
unterstützt wurden sie von
vertreter/innen mehrerer parteien sowie
großer verbände mit dem deutschen
gewerkschaftsbund
im tarifkonflikt mit der
lokführergewerkschaft gdl hat die
deutsche bahn ein neues angebot
vorgelegt sie biete eine zusätzliche
entgelt komponente an teilte das
unternehmen mit die gdl will das neue
angebot prüfen sie hatte der bahn vorher
mit einem weiteren streik gedroht
freiwillig den müll anderer leute
aufsammeln genau das haben heute
tausende an deutschen flussufern gemacht
bei der aktion rein cleanup wie hier am
rheinufer in düsseldorf versammelten sie
flaschen dosen aber auch elektro scooter
ein im vergangenen jahr waren so 320
tonnen müll zusammengekommen diesmal
wurde über die gesamte länge des rheins
gesammelt von der schweiz bis nach
rotterdam
in der wissenschaft kommt es ja oft auch
auf ausdauer an deshalb heißt so nämlich
auf englisch provence auch der mars
rover der nasa der rumpelt nun schon
seit monaten über die oberfläche des
roten planeten und jetzt ist es ihm
gelungen gesteinsproben an bord zu holen
und sie auch gleich zu analysieren was
dabei herauskam verschlug den
forschenden den atem warum zeigt ihn jan
frederik fischer
aus diesem felsen stammen sie die
winzigen gesteinsproben von der sich die
wissenschaft derzeit großes verspricht
denn nach einer ersten analyse steht
fest
die kleinen körnchen vom roten planeten
enthalten eine sensation und die heißt
sei
das vorhandensein von salz weist darauf
hin dass das gestein dem wasser
ausgesetzt war dieses ist durch das
gestein gedrungen und hat beim
versickern und verdunsten einen salzigen
rückstand hinterlassen salz heißt wasser
wasser heißt vielleicht leben gab es das
jemals auf dem mars der antwort auf
diese uralte frage sind die forscher nun
möglicherweise einen schritt näher
gekommen bis es gewissheit geben wird
wird es aber noch dauern zwar hat es der
rover geschafft zwei proben zu sammeln
aber die größte herausforderung steht
noch an die gesteine müssen sicher zur
erde gebracht werden frühestens ab 2030
ist das geplant und erst dann können die
wissenschaftler selbst überprüfen ob sie
wirklich hinweise gefunden haben auf
leben auf dem roten planeten
und wir kommen zurück zur erde und zum
aus von ex an als wäre es bei den us
open hat ja bei der wiederauflage des
olympischen halbfinal duells von tokio
gegen den weltranglisten ersten novak
djokovic zog deutschlands bester
tennisspieler diesmal in new york den
kürzeren es wäre unterlag nach großem
kampf mit 2 3 sätzen
nach drei stunden und 34 minuten
weltklasse-tennis verwandelt novak
djokovic seinen ersten matchball
alexander zverev mit tollem start
gewinnt den ersten satz 6 zu 4 djokovic
den 262 im umkämpften dritten satz der
spektakulärste ballwechsel
53 mal fliegt der ball übers netz punkt
wäre doch den satz holte sich djokovic 6
zu 4 zverev kämpft sich mit 6 4 und 4
zurück
immer in den entscheidenden momenten
kamen seien auf schlag so gut dass ich
dann gar nicht erst ins spiel kamen im
fünften satz spiel djokovic seine
erfahrung aus und gewinnt sechs zu zwei
djokovic kann im finale gegen daniel
medwedew auch das vierte grand slam
turnier in diesem jahr gewinnen
zur fußball bundesliga hat der vfb vfl
wolfsburg die tabellenführung gefestigt
durch den sieg in fürth hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse des vierten
spieltages führt gegen wolfsburg 0 2
leverkusen verliert in einem packenden
spiel gegen dortmund 4 union berlin
gegen augsburg 0 0 freiburg gegen köln 1
1 hoffenheim unterliegt mainz mit 0 2
das abendspiel leipzig gegen bayern aus
für dich bei uns zu sehen im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23.30 blick auf die
tabelle wolfsburg erst vier spiele vier
siege zwölf punkte dahinter jetzt
dortmund und mainz mit jeweils neun
punkten es folgen freiburg und
leverkusen die bayern sechster sie
könnten aber heute abend noch auf platz
zwei klettern die zweite tabellenhälfte
beginnt mit r b und ganz hinten gladbach
führt und die noch punktlose härter
einstand nach maß für cristiano ronaldo
beim ersten einsatz nach seiner rückkehr
zu manchester united trifft er gleich
zweimal beim 4 2 1 1 gegen newcastle
er ist zurück in manchester der
portugiesische superstar und er macht
gleich das was er am besten kann einem
spiel seinen stempel aufdrücken und tore
erzielen kurz vor der pause sein 10 12
jahre und 118 tage nach seinem letzten
einsatz für united riesige ronaldo
euphorie in manchester in der 62 minute
sein zweiter treffer zum 2 1 er
brilliert und er bestimmt die
schlagzeilen cristiano ronaldo beim 4 2
1 sieg von manchester
[Applaus]
titel hattrick für jessica von bredow
wandel und ihre stute der lehrer bei den
dressur europameisterschaften
mit großem abstand gewinnt ihr
olympiasiegerin die grand prix kür und
holte damit ihr drittes em-gold im
niedersächsischen hann dagegen geht
dieser bewährt mit ihrer stute weil gold
erstmals seit sechs jahren bei einem
großen championat leer aus und wird
führte
das was vom sport dankeschön arbeiten
noch zum wetter das beruhigt sich wieder
die einzelheiten hat gleich ist intelli
für sie christian sievers begrüßt sie um
23.15 zum heute journal
schönen abend
[Musik]
ein schön kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter dieses tief hier bei grünland
das ist der rest von hurricane larry und
das ist derartig in die strömung
reingegrätscht dass das tief vor spanien
quasi abgerissen ist und dort liegen
bleibt es wird in den nächsten tagen
richtung iberische halbinsel ziehen und
hier für kräftige regenfälle sorgen bei
uns herrscht hoher luftdruck und somit
ruhiges wetter und teils viel
sonnenschein in der nacht gibt es wenige
schauer im westen und im norden sonst
generell im norden viele wolken nach
süden bildet sich nebel bei tiefsten
temperaturen von neun grad im westen und
16 grad an der nordsee und
morgen im tagesverlauf wieder viel sonne
nur nach norden hin ist es dichter
bewölkt ganz im norden gibt es schauer
oder auch nach osten hin und das bei
höchsten temperaturen von 25 grad im
südwesten und zum beispiel 19 grad an
der nordsee die kommenden tage werden
wärmer am montag viel sonne vor allem im
südwesten bis 26 dienstag bis 27 grad
dazu gewitter und am mittwoch wird es
wieder wechselhaft mit schauern und
gewittern damit einen schönen abend